I tell you the last two panels are
reasons why people in Washington like
and you like to get out of Washington
and listen to the great experiences at
the state and local level is brilliant
and all of you have the same good
fortune in this panel as well because we
have three exceptionally proficiently
professional presenters so again we have
three great speakers will start with
royd agrawala director of New York City
mayor's office of long-term planning and
sustainability when red joined the
Bloomberg administration 2006 he was
charged with creating the office of
long-term planning and sustainability
and developing a long-term strategy for
New York City for the year 2030 grid led
the development of what became how do
you pronounce a plat plan YC plan YC a
greener Greater New York the city
sustainability plan which the mayor
released on earth day April 22nd 2007
Mayor Bloomberg said recently of red
quote he is a farsighted and creative
thinker whose inspiration and work ethic
allowed us to develop and then put in
place a 20-year vision for improving the
city that our children and grandchildren
will inherit on court weighty words but
I'm sure your well deserved so red tell
us tell us why Mayor Bloomberg thinks so
highly well um and you've got 10 minutes
to do so hey appreciated thank you grip
and thanks to to Yale for for this event
this important topic and I thought what
I would talk about using the Cicero's
approach I'm not going to talk about how
much progress we've made on hybrid taxis
I'm not going to talk about how we've
done really impressive things to my mind
on getting new york city ready for
climate change from a resilience and
adaptation point of view i'm not going
to talk about transit oriented
development but what i am actually going
to try to talk about is is the way we
think of this concept of leading by
example and something that we've done i
think in a couple of places related to
plan wise see that again building on the
earlier comments may or may not be truly
best practice but
think worked pretty well for us and
merit some thinking and that's the
actual integration of what a government
entity does for itself and the
connection between that and its
policy-making role and so in the area of
green buildings one of our biggest
achievements last year in fact I would
argue the single most important thing
we've done related to climate change
policy in New York and through plan YC
was the passage of the greener greater
buildings plan which was a package of
laws for bills and two mayoral
initiatives that was passed we four
bills were passed into law last December
proposed last April in fact mayor
Nichols and Mayor Bloomberg both
presented one on each coast a major
package of similar legislation on the
same day and hopefully Seattle also
passed a good chunk of theirs as well
recently to require the systemic
upgrades of large buildings in New York
City over time we targeted those
buildings that are 50,000 square feet
and above although there are only 20,000
out of the roughly million buildings in
the city of New York they take care of
about half of our total square footage
and it imposes a comprehensive approach
of requiring annual benchmarking that we
hope will drive valuations and make
building owners more aware of their
energy performance and drive competition
among real estate managers a long term
requirement of changing lighting and
imposing submetering and commercial
spaces that we think will take in both
tenant and central spaces the biggest
low-hanging fruit which is of course
lighting as well as realign some
misaligned incentives because we still
have an awful lot of commercial space in
New York City that's based on electric
renton inclusion and therefore no
incentive to reduce plug loads a process
of auditing and retro-commissioning
that's going to be required every ten
years every large building in New York
City starting in 2013 with an early
compliance
procedure to incentivize people to get
it done in the near term we'll have to
do an energy audit and then have to do a
retro-commissioning the tune-up of
building systems that can depending on
on the building can get anywhere from
five to ten percent right there with no
capital investment or minimal capital
investment and then finally we did
tighten and take local control of our
energy code interestingly enough until
July first when the law takes effect the
only of the important codes related to
buildings in New York City the
construction code the fire code the
electrical whatever the only one where
New York City actually relied on the
state code entirely was the energy code
and as a result it was never really
tailored for our building stock and so
now based on the new york state energy
while we're taking local control closing
some loopholes loopholes and we're going
to have the flexibility to add things
over time but what as big a policy
initiative is that was one of the things
i just like to describe here is that
critical to it was the fact that we had
already started doing it to our own
buildings and so what allowed us to
succeed in a year year and a half really
worth of detailed conversations and
negotiations with real estate interests
with tenants with all sorts of people
around the city about this package to
get very much into the weeds of what the
implications were any unintended
consequences the complications of how
people would have to comply or the fact
that starting in 2007 we had already
begun this whole portfolio approach to
New York City's own buildings sitting
owns about 3,000 structures ranging from
police precinct houses to public schools
including the Municipal Building which
is a 30-story skyscraper and of course a
lot of single storey buildings
particularly in the boroughs and that
comprises between six and seven percent
given the year of new york city's total
energy consumption
is new york city government the city has
a billion dollar-a-year energy budget
for city government and so setting as
mayor bloomberg in 2007 set a 30 x 30
reduction target for the citywide carbon
footprint we also set a 30 x 17 so in 10
years goal for doing so in the city
government's own carbon footprint and
that I think really across the board has
given us a lot of credibility but even
more so the day-to-day difficulty and
lessons of actually implementing a
system-wide benchmarking so we've
already got we had as of last year we
got the whole public school system into
the portfolio manager tool 1300 public
schools in New York City are actually
right now in the process of dumping into
the system the rest of the roughly 1,500
buildings the city owns having done that
centrally through our local version of
the GSA that's actually one lesson that
doing the central is so much easier than
doing it on a building by building basis
but it also allowed us to see how
frequent some of the data gaps that
building owners and managers often said
well wait a minute but it's actually not
that easy necessarily to get the outside
square footage and doesn't that make a
big difference and things like that that
had brun been brought to our attention
and I think in retrospect if we had just
looked at this as a policy proposal
rather than also looking at it as a
landlord ourselves we would not have
understood some of the issues that
people brought to us we would not have
been able to know in fact whether they
were real whether they were smoke
screens whether they were solvable
whether they were were nuisances but not
actually major challenges the same thing
happened when we were doing energy audit
so historically New York City over the
last 10 years working with the New York
State Energy Research and Development
Authority has been doing energy audits
on its buildings but it did so at the
rate of roughly ten a year and as you
can imagine if you've got a building
stock of 3000 and you're doing 10 a year
they change over rate is not going to
get you very far but one of the things
we found for example was the standard
audit type we
were doing was an ashtray level 3 an
investment-grade audit which given that
we aren't doing specific project
financing on each individual project was
a gold-plated level of analysis when all
we really needed was a managerial level
of analysis because we were making our
own decisions and so it was based on
that that we really understood from
firsthand experience what it was to
shift from the level 3 standard to what
we are now putting in place and
expanding our ability this year we will
have done a hundred energy audits which
is just shy of not quite at the run rate
we need to comply with our own law going
forward but that meant that we have a
team that's now essentially doubled in
size over at the Department of citywide
administrative services that knows what
it is to do a at scale comprehensive
audit approach similarly we're in the
process right now of a portfolio type
retro-commissioning approach that will
look at operations and maintenance
processes in a wide range of city
buildings all at once so that we know
how to do it and I think it's that kind
of experience that is what really makes
leading by example necessary I think we
all know that leadership by example can
inspire because it will lead people to
imitate what you do I think we all
appreciate and particularly policy
people and elected officials such as I'm
sitting with know that you never have
credibility unless you're willing to put
your money where your mouth is and
that's the other reason to do leadership
by example but as I look back at the
last several years I think in fact what
was most valuable for us and if our
green buildings laws are in fact
successful are in fact as easy to comply
with as I think they will be in fact I
believe will produce far more savings
than the five percent cut in our city
wide carbon footprint that we've
projected from it if that's true I think
we will look back and think that the
biggest benefit we got from leadership
by example was actually the fact that we
got really smart about the policies we
were going to ask other people to do
having tried them ourselves thank you
well thank you very much for it I think
the mayor is right now now just just
just to demonstrate and just to prove
that not all good examples come from the
east coast our next presenters are going
to buy the west coast and as a person
who grew up in the Great Pacific
Northwest I'm very happy to see Valerie
and Greg Nickels here we'll start with
Valerie Brown who is the vice chair of
the Sonoma County California Board of
Supervisors and was elected president of
the National Association of counter
counties on July fifteenth 2009 Ms Brown
was appointed by the governor to
represent sonoma county's first district
in august 2002 and was elected to a full
term later that year Valerie tell us
what's going on in California I wrote it
adore doing that actually this is an
interesting panel that you put together
because we were all in Copenhagen for
cop15 in December and using all of our
leadership skills to try to move an
agenda forward which recognized local
government and what I'm going to do
today is kind of talk to you about three
different levels of leadership because
those are kind of the levels that I
experience in the roles that I have I
sit on the ically USA board and the
objective in any kind of global
agreement that comes up recognizing what
we're dealing with in terms of climate
protection is that local government is
somehow identified as a partner or a
person at the table and currently that's
not so we find that very often to be the
the what occurs but we and local
government know that most innovation
most best practices do come from local
government and so we really need to be
at that table so on the on the global
level we're doing everything that we can
to work with partners throughout the
throughout the global enterprises
through united states and local
governments and through some other
organizations to try to make sure
regardless of what the conversations are
they include local government the next
level for me is as the president of the
National Association of counties we have
been incredibly energized even though
seventy percent of our counties and
there are 3,000 counties in the United
States I'm sorry Connecticut doesn't
have any but 2600 of them belonged to
the National Association of counties we
have about seventy percent of those
counties that are rather rural and
nature kind of conservative and they're
thinking haven't quite come on board
with the issue of global warming however
in this new administration federal
administration watching what they're
doing around do e grants watching what
they're doing around sustainable
Louisville communities all of a sudden
there's money and so they want to be
involved in that so they're rethinking
maybe they'll do away with the global
warming piece and maybe become more
involved in how can we get that money
into our communities so it's a it's a
it's a very interesting money does speak
pretty loudly and so at the National
Association we formed a green government
initiative that was in partnership with
private industries and I put some
materials out on the desk for you but
those of you who may be watching it
later they can go that to the NAC o or
website and get any of them but you can
you can see on the documents I'm giving
you a wonderful list of partners and
what we're trying to do is coalesce
information in a way that we can
distribute it give people an idea about
what opportunities they have what
partnerships from regional or from an
independent basis that they can absorb
themselves in and and perhaps be more
energy efficient we're also finding that
it really doesn't make any difference
where you live kids are starting to pay
attention and they're driving the
message up to elected leaders that they
need to be paying attention to they need
to do more recycling they need to turn
off the water tap they need to pay
attention to what's green and what's not
so I think and I think a lot of young
parents are
the same so it's caused elected leaders
to look a little differently at their
policy development I'd like to now drill
it down to the local level for me I live
in Sonoma County California i'm actually
the chairman of the board of directors
our Board of Supervisors we have five
supervisors in sonoma county is four
hundred and eighty thousand people and
we have a very energetic aggressive
policy around climate protection i'm
thinking that it's probably cause we all
will have a half-full glass of wine with
us but maybe or maybe not the truth is
we all of our nine cities and our county
signed resolutions and i think one of
our earlier speakers talked about the
need to work together and come to some
kind of cooperative system among elected
officials all nine cities in the county
signed on to resolutions to reduce
greenhouse gases twenty five percent
below the 1990 levels by the year 2015
incredibly aggressive what it did though
is it was a wake-up call to the
community to rethink how we what our
carbon footprints were what our
transportation policies were when our
land use policies were what our issues
around bike safety pedestrian
passageways and it pushed us in a
totally different direction and the
first thing that we realized is that it
was probably going to be harder to get
people out of their cars than it was
good to get them to retrofit their homes
or their businesses so we lobbied with a
palm desert in Berkeley to get a
legislation with which authorized us to
do voluntary benefit assessment
districts meaning that we could with
some backing of money offer up permanent
retrofits for homes and for commercial
enterprises and move that into a play
the real pace funding then move it onto
the property taxes we opened our program
of March of 2009 we required an audit of
our commercial industries we did not
require one of
residential we thought it would be
somewhat of a disability for folks they
wouldn't want to do it they had their
ideas about what they wanted to do
whether it was solar or whatever so we
didn't require but probably in the next
iteration of this ordinance we will be
requiring it and I'll tell you why so we
started this a year ago we have a water
agency that delivers water to 600,000
residents as part of our county and we
were able to come up with 75 million
from the water agency 25 million from
our county would put it in a pot and
that became the backing for the money to
allow people to do what they needed to
do I'm proud to say that a march of 2010
we had had 45 million dollars in
applications we are now realizing that
we really do need to reduce the rate of
the of the of the interest we're about
at seven percent now so we're really
moving in two directions we're of the
belief that if it is a permanent
retrofit and it can go from window
exchanged irrigation to anything that
stays with a house it is a value for
someone to use that mechanism rather
than to use a home equity loan because
obviously if you use the home equity
loan in five years later you move from
the house you're still paying off the
home equity loan if you purchase the rut
ro you do the retrofits and you sell
your house in five years the retrofits
stay with the house and they stay on the
property tax we're doing it at 5 10 15
and 20 year assessments we have found
that people are making interesting
decisions about what energy efficiency
projects they want to have in their
houses sometimes it comes from the roof
salesman that came out to their house
and said everybody in your neighborhood
is proving their roofs it's a great
insulation model you just don't know
it's going to be you're going to save X
amount of energy they believe it it's
kind of like the old asphalt salesman in
the driveway but it's working
we've we are finding that people are
gravitating towards solar because
there's a lot more emphasis on solar
there's a lot more advertising on solar
and that may not say them and I out of
energy so some of us on the board
decided that we needed to lead by
example as you say and we decided to
have personal energy audits not a pretty
picture by the way I'm going to tell you
right now it is it's a it's a it's a
very difficult thing to believe that
you've lived in the house that's very
safe secure and air is not leaking out
from every every orifice and then you
find out that it is and you find that
you would have to put it for me for my
own house I was going to have to put in
twenty five thousand dollars worth of
retrofit before I ever got to solar so
because of the experiences that we have
had we are now talking about the need
for energy audits and that everyone
needs to do it and we actually received
a grant from our california energy
commission that is going to allow us to
provide 75% of that energy audit so the
customer is only paying for twenty-five
percent and they can put that on the
property taxes what we've noticed in
california is that it's been a huge job
creator probably one of the largest
Momentum's and job creations especially
at a time when jobs are we're losing
jobs everywhere and we did a little
study of three counties in the vicinity
for two of the county's they had a
negative two percent reduction in
construction jobs we had a positive
seven percent so we know that it's
making a difference and we know that
it's working in the long run the last
piece of this is that we we really would
like some kind of tax-exempt bonding
mechanism I mean everybody realizes that
that's a way to go congressman Thompson
who haven't still live in our area is
carrying a bill HR 35 25 which is
exactly for that purpose it allows for
tax-exempt bonds to be issued for
refined
dancing in in in specific cases like
these programs of these pace programs
that are out there we had our auditor
our auditor-controller speak to the Ways
and Means Committee last week he
absorbed a lot of questions a lot of
questions about double dipping a lot of
questions about how's this going to work
how much you're going to need what to
have you know all the typical questions
but I think they got it and so we're
hoping that we're going to be able to
move them something through that process
if not we're hoping we can move it under
the Buy America Bonds act so that maybe
we can use in another so I'm throwing
the net out to all of you that are here
and invested in this it really is time
for us to speak with one voice if we
want something done at the federal level
to allow us to continue the kind of
projects which I think are there's no
question or working and creating jobs
and a huge economic bonus to our
communities thank you thank you very
much Valerie the $25,000 retrofit tab I
must have been sobering but but good for
you for leading by example I just have
to move my furniture off the vents that
would be the first thing
that's kind of a woman thing sorry our
next speaker is Greg Nickels who served
as the 51st mayor of the city of seattle
from january first 2002 through december
31st 2009 following the completion of a
second term as mayor mr. Nichols
received a prestigious fellowship with
the Institute of Politics at Harvard
University Harvard are we able to thank
you for welcoming me despite that sorry
at some other Ivy League school up in
another state where he is residence for
spring semester 2010 mayor Nichols
earned an international reputation for
his leadership on climate protection
Rolling Stone magazine called him the
Pied Piper of Mayors for his work to
protect our climate and the US
Environmental Protection Agency awarded
him its 2006 climate protection award on
februari 16 2005 mayor Nichols pledged a
Seattle would lower its emissions by the
amount called for the Kyoto Protocol
which went into effect that day in 141
countries but as we all remember not in
the United States he began an effort to
analysts mayor's across the country to
pledge to do the same over 1,000 mayor's
representing 86 million Americans of
mouse I in the u.s. mayor's climate
protection agreement agreeing to reduce
emissions voluntarily by seven percent
from 1990 levels by 2012 great
accomplishment mayor Nichols tell us
what you're doing thank you very much
it's usually at this point of the
program that somebody will observe that
everything's been said but not by
everybody so I'm going to depart a
little bit and kind of tell you the
story of how I as a mayor of a moderate
sized American city got involved in this
global issue because I didn't set out to
do that I became mayor 2002 and climate
change was something I cared about as a
human being and I assumed that we had
some time to deal with it and I I knew
for a fact that our federal government
had smart people who are working on it
and it turned out that I was wrong
and it came clear to me a couple of
years later actually the winter of 2004
2005 and in the Pacific Northwest that
was a very dry winter and a very warm
winter we had 60 degree days in january
that's very unusual in seattle and that
meant there was no ski season in the
Cascade Mountains which was a tragedy
for many people but for me as mayor it
was more troubling because we rely on
that snow in the mountains to melt in
the spring we capture it and we use it
for water for the people of Seattle and
about a million people around Seattle
and we use it to run through turbines to
provide green electricity year-round and
so no water there's no ability to create
that electricity and so the mayor of
tacoma washington a city just south to
seattle and i got on the radio and we're
urging people to shower together and
that even in seattle is a radical
concept so that's why I took the Kyoto
pledge when it became law I thought
there was a moment in time that we might
be able to focus the attention of the
American people and the people at
Seattle on this issue and again for me
it was a local issue century-old
sustainable systems for water and for
power were at risk and it wasn't a
one-time event but it is a trend since
the end of World War two that that
snowpack has been shrinking so when you
make a statement like that there are two
things you can do you can simply make it
and get a headline and in walk away from
it or you can try and follow that up
with action and as I urged other cities
to join with Seattle because I knew if
it was Jes Seattle it would be purely
symbolic and it's very difficulty of
people to change behavior for purely
symbolic reasons it seemed to me that
Seattle needed to walk its talk needed
to show that we were trying our best to
meet that reduction and to do it in
innovative and creative ways and we
started by leading by example
we took a look at our own corporate
emissions as a city and we reduce those
by sixty percent from 1990 levels so we
could go out to the Seattle community
and say we've done this as an
organization it didn't break the bank
and we think that as a community we can
now step up and do it citywide I engage
the Civic and business leadership the
environmental leadership and a green
ribbon task force and I charged them
with coming up with a plan for Seattle
much like plan NYC it was to reduce our
missions by six hundred and eighty
thousand metric tons which represents
seven percent from 1990 levels for
Seattle and they went about that work
and came up with a great menu of
opportunities for a politician to
basically make almost anybody in our
community uncomfortable and maybe angry
but that would get us to that seven
percent from 1990 levels and so we began
to implement that plan at the same time
we recognize that Kyoto is just
scratching the surface that we need to
go an order of magnitude beyond that in
order to really affect the this
phenomena and so we asked all of the
mayor's who join this effort to not only
take leadership locally in reducing
emissions but also to join together and
advocate for a federal cap-and-trade
system and federal legislation but even
when we get to the point where Congress
acts and I don't know if anyone hears
brave enough to predict when that will
be but when they act it will be a very
weak bill despite all the efforts of the
good people in this room and people all
over this country it will be a very
compromised bill because it will need to
take care of the cold states it'll need
to take care of the Northeast and the
southwest and everybody in between and
that's okay that's okay because it will
represent a commitment by the people of
the United States to deal with this
issue and that's a big step for
forward as Valerie mentioned she and I
and Roy were in Copenhagen I had been in
Montreal five years earlier and as the
mayor who had started the Kyoto Accord
the u.s. mayor's climate protection
agreement my message was very simple in
Montreal and that was there is
intelligent life in America and we will
be back to this issue and we will help
lead on this issue and it was nice to be
in Copenhagen to say we are back we're
not there yet but we're back and we're
going to be a constructive part of the
solution and so I think equally whatever
international treaty comes out of Mexico
next year or maybe it'll be the year
after that or whenever a treaty is
agreed to it also will contain very
serious compromises it will have to
address the concerns of the United
States as well as China as well as
farmers in France and so it will contain
very significant compromises and that's
okay because it will represent a
commitment by humanity to deal with this
issue but what it will also discesa Tate
from each one of us is that we continue
to push the envelope that we not allow
that paper whether it is our our
national legislation or the
international treaty to define a ceiling
for us we're going to need to make sure
that it simply provides a foundation
from which we will continue to push to
reduce our emissions whether it's
through energy efficiency whether it is
through renewables whether it is a
transformation of our transportation
system from fossil fuel to electricity
we will have to push that envelope and
the leadership that we have started at
the local level of that we know are very
confident that we could provide locally
we'll need to continue in order to make
it safe for our members of Congress our
state legislatures and ultimately our
international tribunals to get where we
need to go by 2050 so it's been a
fascinating issue for
a guy from a relatively a small city in
the northwest corner of the United
States last week I had the opportunity
to participate in a teleconference with
about 50 Chinese mayors and they were
wanting to talk about how you create a
low-carbon City and if we had not
stepped up as mayors and local officials
in the US I don't think we would have
been having that conversation and I
don't think that as of yet we have
reestablished our credibility as a
nation on this so that leadership at the
local level will continue to be
necessary we're going to continue to
push the envelope and ultimately will
get the job done well thank you very
much mayor and it is nice to know on the
national level we are back we have a lot
of work to do but working with the
special envoy for climate change
toddster and let me tell you there's a
whole department that's dedicated and
they work very very long hours so it is
nice to be back in the game well you
just 43 great examples of what personal
leadership really means from new york to
sonoma county to seattle it was personal
leadership champions at the political
level to get this stuff done and that's
what's going to take around the world
but we have a few minutes for questions
we have some questions for our panelists
I'm Gabe device from the School of
Management actually have a question for
ya specifically for four main icles but
anyone here can you know can add in as
you correctly pointed out there you know
there has been a vacuum of leadership at
the highest level in this country on
this issue and I think that's widely
recognized both here in America and and
in the rest of the world but i think
it's sometimes easy to blame leaders
when it in reality you know the
leadership is merely a reflection of
society
it to that degree to someone who's been
intimately involved in these debates and
discussions what do you think it is
about the the comments I key in the
narrative in you know in in America that
makes it so much so resistant this idea
and to change when the average European
for example is much more receptive in
fact as you pointed out there were 50
miles from China a country that's you
know at a far lower stage of development
that has you know seemed at least on the
surface to embrace its its global
responsibility in this in this in this
arena what do you think what do you
think drives that well I I'm not a
national politician so so I'm not sure
what it is about our institutions that
makes it so difficult for us to act when
there are clear needs the health care
bill seems to me took far more effort
than it should have to address a crisis
that we all are many many many Americans
have recognized for many many years but
our institutions are not functioning
very well i would suggest though that
the fact that a thousand and thirty
mayor's voluntarily step forward to
agree to reduce the emissions in their
communities indicates there is a
widespread acknowledgement that this is
a very serious problem and that action
is necessary so I you know maybe I'll
steal Valerie's line maybe the glass of
wine is half-full in that 86 million
Americans now have mayor's who have
signed up and are taking that specific
action our national institutions are
much slower to move and I think that's a
problem for us not just on this issue
but on many other issues as well and
something we're going to have to grapple
with as a country you know it was
embarrassing to be in Montreal as an
American with our country actively
undermining any international agreement
from being achieved Copenhagen it was
much less embarrassing to be there
because we were
to be trying to come to an agreement we
weren't successful ultimately but but we
have moved a long way in those five
intervening years if I can take that for
a second there's a change that's
happening that is fascinating to watch
and plays into I think we're all of us
are moving in terms of energy efficiency
and really wanting to see our lives and
our quality of life change around that
the this administration is doing
something that I was in the California
Legislature wasn't I watched now three
administration's pretty closely and I've
never seen this before and it goes
beyond the transparency issue it it you
know we in government have issues around
silos and that you know places you know
you kind of get stuck in your spot and
you never talk to anybody else in the
same government you work in this
administration has decided that one
agencies are going to work together to
agencies are going to coalesce around
some common goals and and at the very
top at the very top is climate
protection it's the window that gets
look through around policy decisions you
find three departments like HUD and EPA
and do t working together to actually
look at how they how they develop
projects how they develop policy how
they fund projects to get toward common
goals around sustainable livable
communities or around energy projects
that makes sense it is a phenomenon it's
a different way of thinking there they
are still in DC that's kind of a problem
in that they they really need this group
here and the academics to be able to
help them get to a place where they
aren't you know just really bogged down
by bureaucracy because it just happens
it's too big a place but and that's why
I think that we are confident in saying
innovation comes from the local level
let us tell you how we do it lettuce
tell you how it works best let us be the
emissary for you in selling the idea out
there to everyone because we can tell
the story just as Greg just did its
powerful story it's better than oh and
by the way we're going to give this
grant and here's where it is and by the
way you you know but they're learning
and it's really only been a year and a
half so I think change is a-comin it's
slower than some of us would like but
it's change I didn't know if we'd even
see in this decade so actually kind of
if I could him sometimes and I we need
to wrap it up but I kind of take issue
with the premise of your comment though
because i think the it's very easy
particularly after the bush
administration on this issue to think oh
what's wrong with us right I mean look
at Canada look at Australia right with
Australia particularly we had this
wonderful change two years ago new
government came in was going to take
action signed Kyoto in Bali and then
lost in in Parliament Canada is
embarrassingly far off from all of its
goals even though on some other issues
that might be aligned with what one
thinks the politics of climate change
arts often be it as a very progressive
country right I I think at the end of
the day if we get away from the question
of what's the American issue with
climate change and actually realize
there are human issues with collective
action with doing things that are in
your long-term interest but not near
short-term interest with acknowledging
the national governments are not
uniformly possessed of the same power
and leadership role around the world in
Europe mo far more is done on the
national level that here we must do on
the state level and I think that our PS
map we saw a little while ago is
actually one of the Europeans don't see
that because they don't do things at the
regional level they only do things at
the national level so it's fundamentally
misleading so I actually would argue I
think to think about it that way is a
prism that will lead us to miss a lot of
both the strengths that this country is
brought to the table
problems that are actually going to be
faced around the world on this issue
excellent plan what time for one more
question time did you have thank you on
my
thanks so much my name is Tom where I'm
from the American Council on the movie
horn and I want to put pants that you
all for a thank you for great comments
and what kind of zoom in on something
going to spartak which is innovation
consume alcohol in your in your terms
terms of these terms what were some
local grassroots efforts especially
looking at renewable energy that you
felt what he made headway and that you
feel are you run cool on a national
scale moving forward with you know
Copenhagen oh well we are actually
looking at something we call applied
solutions and looking at the different
communities County some cities and
putting together a profile of what we
think are best practices that can be
replicated and looking to fund those
best practices so you can have people
visit them and go out you look at
Boulder you look at Santa Fe you look at
Seattle you look at counties across the
country that have decided to take a
sanitation system off the grid by doing
heat pumps and solar you know I don't
know if you've been paying attention but
please do it's really quite a lively
argument about we have propositions in
California and prop 16 which is
currently being run by the utilities who
don't want any community aggregation in
other words they don't want local
governments to be in charge of utilities
because we won't ask people when we raid
the raise the rates I don't remember
them asking us but you know I think it's
an interesting dynamic that's going on
right now and I think the reason that
it's being tested by utility companies
because local governments are finding
new ways to deliver we're putting in
fuel cells we're putting in electric
cars we're putting in kiosk for those
electric cars we're making sure those
kiosks are regional so that people can
drive as far as they want to in them
we're looking at biomass for you know
we're looking at you know it
incinerators instead of landfills we're
doing things that I think are so far out
of the box that it's taking you our
constituents are kind of gasping at it
but they want to go there and it's not
hard to sell them on it as long as not
in their backyard it's the only issue
but but i think is having everywhere
yeah and i would agree i think that
there is a lot of innovation that's
being shown it and that's one of the
strengths of the approach we took is
that you have a thousand and thirty
laboratories and every mayor has an ego
so they want to make a difference on
that issue and make their mark on that
issue a few things that i would point to
from our perspective seattle City Light
our municipally owned utility which is
about the ninth or tenth largest public
utility in the country is the first
major electric utility united states
that it's zero net greenhouse gas
emissions now we have an advantage
because we have a lot of hydro but we
had to get rid of coal out of our
portfolio and we had to move to wind and
and conservation has been our emphasis
as a new resource for many many years we
were the first city in the United States
that put in a bag fee for encouraging
people to reuse bags rather than use
plastic or paper grocery bags it was
rolled back because of a very very steep
investment by the American Chemistry
Council but january first washington DC
put into place a bag fee so they won the
battle in seattle but they're going to
lose the war across the country we are
moving very aggressively in terms of
electric cars we're going to have to
thousands charging stations the Nissan
Leaf will use Seattle is one of a
handful of the markets that they're
going to introduce their leaf in late
this year so we're trying to move our
transportation system which has been
ninety eight and a half percent
dependent on fossil fuels to electric
and in our case since our electricity is
green that's a hundred percent teen
hundred percent reduction so so there's
a lot of innovation going on there's a
group I've got to tell you about that is
the best we now have about 80 different
sustainability groups around Seattle
they formed a group called scallops
Seattle climate action all over Puget
Sound I think is what that stands for
but one of the groups is called cool
moms
young mothers young children the moms
are concerned about what kind of a world
they're leaving to these young infants
and so they have organized themselves
and they're out at every community
picnic and festival getting the word out
about cfl bulbs and low-flow showerheads
and reusable grocery bags and and to me
the most important piece of this is to
engage each individual human being and
changing their own behavior because then
they will expect their elected officials
to take strong action okay well please
join me in thanking them once again for
some great